I had send on this tweet last December
and it went off into the internet and
kind of took on a life of its own which
is kind of amazing actually it still
gets retweeted to this day and to me
it's really just common sense but I'm
not so sure that my common sense is
shared with the digital age that we're
in in the direction that we're going in
unfortunately we live in an incredibly
short cut obsessed society increasingly
defined by shrinking attention spans in
this demand for instant gratification
all you have to do is look at how
Netflix or video on demand killed the
video store and our next thing the next
obsession that we're about to enter into
is Amazon one-hour delivery by drone
right right do we really need this it's
insane right what is happening is that
privilege has become entitlement we've
developed this birthright to overnight
six-pack abs and professional success
envious wealth limitless free time and
in some ways I suspect even salvation
and this trend can be boiled down to one
term it is the meme that is beyond
reproach is the mean that is enjoying
irresistible staying power on every
corner of the Internet
it's the hack right we've all heard the
term hack whoops I went backwards there
but what is a hat what are we talking
about here well a hat really is nothing
more than leveraging a good idea right
it's a strategy to expedite proficiency
in a particular skill or discipline on a
fraction of the time required for
mastery it's the 80/20 rule 80% of the
results on 20% of the time and effort
and there's nothing inherently wrong
with that that's pretty cool actually
but what's amazing is this entire
movement that is blossomed around this
idea right hashtag life hacker bio
hacking weight loss hack Fitness hack
diet hack hack your kids hack your wife
what is going on Google any derivation
of this term and see what comes up and
it's amazing actually there are even
entire conferences built around this
concept like how to have publishing to
hit the New York Times bestseller list
or how to hack email lists to make
millions online where while you're
sailing across the Mediterranean or how
to hack your job and delegate all of
your responsibilities to overseas
virtual assistants
but what's kind of harder to find is
just what it takes to write a great book
that actually deserves to be on the New
York Times bestseller list right or what
constitutes a quality product that would
be worthy of selling or how to best
channel all of this time suddenly freed
up by virtue of delegating all your
responsibilities overseas so this is
nothing new of course the hack is a mere
modern vernacular reframing of practices
and marketing techniques that date back
to the snake oil salesmen in carnival
barkers of you're promising everything
from miracle cures to deliverance with a
sharp convincing preachers tongue that
has us impulsively forking over our
hard-earned coin to the profit of the
moment but the acute nature of this
particular modern Rush is something
distinctively new and I think it's kind
of disturbing it used to be an insult to
call somebody a hack
suddenly it's high praise so what does
that say about us that a term so
historically pejorative has suddenly
become aspirational my personal opinion
is that somewhere along the line
we've lost the thread somewhere along
the line the hack became the destination
rather than the tool and that's insane
that's like becoming obsessed with a
table saw rather than the process of
using it to make a beautiful piece of
furniture destinations personally I
don't give a [ __ ] about destinations I
rarely think about what it was like to
cross the finish line at any of the
races or endurance challenges that I've
done I couldn't tell you what I was
doing or where I was when my book
finally hit bookstore shelves because a
life of meaning a life well-lived
it's not about results it's not about
finish lines or destinations it's about
the journey that we all take it's about
the road less traveled that seeks not to
circumvent
but rather to embrace all the obstacles
the failures the toil the pain that
tears the sweat the missteps the doubt
and the fear to the fullest and without
compromise it's really easy and sexy to
frame a narrative of the overnight
success story you can look at whatsapp
American Idol Instagram even and you'll
notice how the media can twist reality
to amplify ratings or multiply page
views but the idea of the overnight
success story really is anything but I
mean let's look at what's out right
according to the media this is two guys
who were rejected by Twitter and by
Facebook who came up with an idea for an
app and overnight sold it to Facebook
for 19 billion dollars of course that's
not the whole story of course the media
doesn't want you to focus on the 20
shared years of toiling and obscurity
that these guys endured five years of
which was found on whatsapp alone peek
behind the curtain on any so-called
instantaneous triumph and you are
certain to find an objective truth that
does not meet the neatly packaged
narrative because every genuine
sustainable success is birth only by
virtue of incredible persistence
interminable patience a million defeats
rabid dedication and unrelenting passion
for the sake of argument let's suspend
reality for a moment let's assume that
we really could circumvent these
admittedly unsexy yet time-tested
notions of hard work and patience and
dedication that are required to achieve
prosperity or health or life
satisfaction spoiler alert
there is no such thing but I'm up here
and you're over there so you're going to
go on this journey with me right so
we're gonna do this well if you want to
achieve the minimum aptitude threshold
in a particular skill or discipline so
you can tell your friends you know how
to do something or you did something
hack away
implement the shortcut rush to
accomplish the task
check the box bucket list item 54 done
moving on to the next hack right but
when you go home that night and you rest
your head on that pillow and you're all
alone just you and your thoughts nobody
else wants you to ask yourself this one
question how did that experience make
you feel truly be honest with yourself
and if you're like me the answer is
really not much of anything and if
anything kind of a little bit empty but
now let's examine what happens when you
decide to devote yourself entirely to
becoming the very best that you could be
it's something you are inherently
passionate about what happens then this
is the anti hack I call mastery suddenly
the heart starts to be faster right the
palms are sweating what's going on ooh
maybe it's excitement
maybe but more likely it's fear because
total dedication total commitment well
that is about as scary as it gets truly
because if you take that risk if you put
yourself completely on the line and fail
or succeed dude you are going to have to
reckon with yourself and that is truly
terrifying when I was 12 years old I was
a terrible student I was horribly
uncoordinated I was a repeat victim of
bullying on the playground I was the kid
who was always picked last for kickball
nonetheless by the time I was 18 I was a
world ranked swimmer I got into all the
colleges I applied to I was in a very
fortunate position of having to say no
to Harvard so I could go to Stanford
instead what was my hack how did I rig
the system to achieve that result I
busted my ass I got up at 4:30 every
morning to go to swim practice before
school swim practice after school and
studied late into the night there was no
shortcuts there was only an obsession
with transcending my life circumstance
at the time in my 20s
alcoholism killed my dreams then it
nearly killed me and my 30s I was able
to get sober but I was able to achieve
sobriety only because I prioritized my
sobriety above everything else had I
tried to hack it or find a shortcut in
my recovery most likely I'd be dead I
certainly wouldn't be standing up here
the best-case scenario is
I'd be living a miserable life somewhere
as a drunk then by 39 I'd succumbed to a
sober yet highly disillusioned middle
life malaise I was hopelessly addicted
to fast food unhealthy lifestyle habits
I was 50 pounds overweight and I was on
a crash course with depression obesity
and heart disease so it was time once
again for another radical life
transformation at the age of 42 I was
able to do it I was named one of the 25
fittest men in the world by Men's
Fitness Magazine like as an aside please
I don't believe that I'm actually one of
one of or ever was one of the 25 fittest
men in the world but when you have a
book that you're trying to sell this is
very effective that's a pro tip for free
I was given that title because I I did
quite well to race called Ultraman it's
this ludicrous double Ironman Triathlon
is a three hundred twenty mile insane
race all the way around the island of
Hawaii and I did fairly well on that the
following year I went on to do the epic
five that Jason kind of introduced me
with five Iron Man's on five wine
islands and five we were trying to do in
five days took a little bit longer about
seven days it was something that a
friend and I attempted that no one else
had ever even tried we were the first
people to ever do it so how do you go
from a guy who's thirty-nine fifty
pounds overweight to this super fit guy
in his 40s
what's the hack there tell me the
shortcut what's the secret smoothie that
you drink in the morning a secret
workout right no I busted my ass it's
completely committed to changing my life
I devoted myself completely to this
that's the hack so looking back it all
seems to make perfect sense how events
unfolded in my life to take me from
where I was to where I am today but you
have to understand that in the midst of
it all it was never linear it was
generally a chaotic terrifying madness
teetering on disaster all the time and
punctuated by countless lows and
gut-wrenching come-to-jesus moments my
favorite story from this period of my
life was the time I was five hours into
an eight-hour training ride getting
ready for my first vultureman race and I
balmed bonking is cycling parlance for
when you run out of energy and it's not
it doesn't mean just being tired it
means you're lightheaded you can't see
straight like you can't go any further I
was in the middle of nowhere I kind of
pulled up in front of a grungy roadside
hamburger stand I had no food on me I
had no money on me
I had a debit card but the problem is my
bank account was overdrawn we were in a
financial crisis at the time I was
starving I was lightheaded and I was too
embarrassed and too ashamed to ask for
help or to ask for some free food so I
resorted to go in behind the restaurant
and dumpster diving for half-eaten
french fries just so I could get some
calories in me
and crawl my way home on the bike it
sounds kind of funny now actually it
sounds pathetic but it was pathetic but
the irony is that looking back on that
experience that's one of my favorite
memories I think about that day all the
time I think about that day way more
than I think about what it was like to
cross a finish line or any other of
successes that I've had in my life it's
an extremely valuable memory that I
would not change for anything because
failure or success or at least the
prospect of failure or success this is
what gives our lives proper context
towering emotional and spiritual stakes
that fertilize our soul for quantum
growth irrespective of outcome and
growth is everything but growth can only
result from earned investment in
experience so fear commitment these
aren't things to be avoided or short
circuited or things we're trying to find
a hack or a shortcut around there's
things to be embraced embraced with
everything that you have and everything
that you are I'm nothing special I'm
absolutely convinced that if I could
repeatedly and so radically and
drastically change my life that
traumatic sustainable change resides
within all of us
growth isn't just possible growth is
what we were put on earth here to do
growth is our mandate there's a YouTube
filmmaker that I'm a big fan of his name
is Casey nice dad he lives in New York
City and I had the great opportunity of
going and visiting him in his studio
last winter and interviewing him for my
podcast and he related to me his
guaranteed recipe for success and I'm
going to share it with you because I
think it captures my anti hack ethos
perfectly it's really simple
and it goes like this
all you have to do is to commit your
life entirely to something and this will
result in one of two outcomes either you
will succeed or you will die trying
which in and of itself is its own form
of success right simple enough there's
nothing sexy there's nothing meme worthy
about the journey the journey is hard
the journey is painful it's not linear
it's not glossy and it will never trend
on Twitter that's a guarantee but if you
aspire to your own personal sense of
greatness if you aspire to push the
envelope on what you're capable of then
forget about the hack instead invest
invest in mastery learn how to toil in
obscurity hold yourself publicly
accountable for your goals let go of
perfection detach from results allow
yourself to fail and fail and fail again
and when all is lost you pick yourself
up off the floor and you go the extra
mile the limits that we impose upon
ourselves these are mental projections
they are illusions we must embrace the
very real possibility that we are so
much more than we allow ourselves to be
right I can't promise you that this path
will translate into success the way that
our society inappropriately defines the
term financial reward fancy friends
accolades
I can't even promise you a single
Facebook like
more likely than not derision will be
what you will receive and I've received
a lot of that over the time but I can
absolutely guarantee you that this
exploration will infuse your life with a
sense of meaning and a sense of purpose
that no destination by a shortcut could
ever rival happiness now I'm not talking
about happiness in the sense of unicorns
and rainbows I'm talking about a deep
satisfaction that your life has value a
value that can be shared shared as
inspiration in service to others who
feel stuck in their lives imprisoned by
a thinking mind that is hardwired to
prioritize the illusion of security and
the illusion of comfort over the
priceless nests of adventure and
experience nothing changes if nothing
changes but as the Chinese say do
something 40 times a day for 40 years
and you just might figure something out
right and the journey to figuring out
the how that is the path to figuring out
the big it this is the promise of the
warrior path this is the art of living
with purpose and this is what it means
to be truly alive a promise no hat can
give you not now not ever thank you